the only Senate seat picked up by
Democrats so far is a battleground state
of Nevada first term congressman
congresswoman rather Jackie Rosen
defeated Republican senator Dean Heller
in one of the closest contest of the
night on a night when win it women are
winning up and down the ballot this is a
historic night for us because now Nevada
joins to be the fifth state with two
women senators she's not looking so
wacky right now Jamie yuccas is outside
Caesars Palace in Las Vegas where Rosen
celebrated with her supporters Jamie
good morning to you good morning it was
a very late night for Democrats here
volunteers were even late to their party
many of them driving voters last-minute
to the polls just minutes before they
closed but all those efforts seem to
have paid off with a win for Jackie
Rosen over the past 48 hours Rosen had
rallied and canvassed nearly non-stop
she won here with a large backing from
the culinary Union which she was
actually part of when she worked as a
waitress at Caesar's Palace during
college 40 years ago this was one of the
Democrats best chances to flip a Senate
seat incumbent Dean Heller was the only
Republican senator up for re-election in
a state the Democratic presidential
nominee Hillary Clinton won in 2016
Heller did both low-key meet-and-greets
and large rallies with President Trump
Heller was once a critic of the
president but the two had aligned when
it came to repealing the Affordable Care
Act now Heller said last night this was
the first time in 30 years he had a call
an opponent and concede during election
CBS News exit polling shows that health
care was the main issue and that is what
Rosen ran her campaign on John yes Jamie
thank you